bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je vous
parlais du nouveau modèle de one plus le
one plus si ce qui pourrait arriver très
bientôt et justement il ya plein d'infos
plein de rumeurs les choses hyper
consciente et on va regarder ça
maintenant
one + a vraiment fait parler de lui en
2017 avec son opus 500 vols + 5 t hélas
cette année pour y remettre le couvert
avec le web + 6 d'ailleurs ils
pourraient ils vont remettre le couvert
avec le one + 6 avec le monde + 5 t il
sont vraiment rentrés encore plus dans
la cour des grands avec un smartphone
d'une excellente qualité et surtout avec
un rapport qualité prix qui bat
quasiment tout le monde un produit qui
est vraiment super et qui a énormément
de critiques positif
autant vous dire que one plus en 2018
est vraiment attendu au tournant sur les
modèles antérieurs avant 2017 si c'était
effectivement déjà connus pour avoir des
produits de bonne qualité
par contre le design était pas forcément
au rendez vous les produits étaient pas
hyper sexy en 2017 ils ont besoin d'un
grand coup de pied dans la fourmilière
lorraine +5 c'est déjà un super modèle
mais avec l'écran 18/9 le one + 5 t ils
ont vraiment fini de confirmer une
position qui est vraiment extrêmement
fortes dans les modèles milieu de gamme
alors à quoi pourrait ressembler ce one
+ 6 qui devrait arriver cette année au
mois de juin à ya déjà plein d'infos qui
sert qu à droite à gauche
bien évidemment je les fais un petit
condensé tout ça pour faire le portrait
robot de ce one + 6 avant toute chose je
vous demande un petit quelque chose vous
allez mettre la pause à la vidéo et vous
allez marquer en commentaire ce que vous
vous voudriez du one + 6 vous avez
forcément votre idée sur le web plus si
ce à quoi il devrait ressembler et
quelles innovations on devrait retrouver
dans ces produits
et même justement ce qu'on ne devrait
pas y retrouver quels sont les travers
de notre marque qui ne devrait pas
prendre vous mettez la pause tout de
suite tout de suite vous marquez tout ça
en commentaire et ensuite on revient à
les y nous voilà de retour normalement
qui de retour parce que vous avez mis la
pause si vous avez pas me la pose c'est
pas bien grave
vocalement aller voir les commentaires
des autres parce que je pense qu'il ya
des choses qui sont très intéressantes
le one + 6 va être un des modèles phares
de 2018 pas ce qui va avoir une fiche
technique d'extrême bonne qualité avec
un produit qui sera dans les tarifs
milieu de gamme un peu plus de 500 euros
ils vont passer le cap
mais vous allez voir que la fiche
technique normalement devrait être
carrément super sexy alors je cette fois
ci c'est un point positif ou un point
négatif c'est un petit peu en tout cas
le point de regret que j'ai eue au mwc
c'est effectivement voir une espèce
d'uniformisation des
il empoche au niveau des smartphones
tout simplement parce que les fabricants
ont toujours tendance à suivre
le numéro un du marché le numéro un
c'est apple son iphone 10 cents en poche
donc l'encoche on la retrouve chez
beaucoup de constructeurs avec des
formes relativement différente
à quelque chose près et oued plus ne
devrait pas manquer à l'appel avec une
encoche qui seraient présentes en haut
de l'écran du one + 6 très clairement
c'est encore chez elle un sens ça permet
effectivement d'agrandir les écrans
néanmoins de garder l'emplacement pour
l'appareil photo pour la reconnaissance
faciale pour le haut parleur et
effectivement c'est pas trop bête de
l'intégrer on pourrait effectivement se
dire qu'ils allaient faire comme samsung
ne pas mettre dans cochons et avoir un
très grand écran l'écran infiniti a
priori ça ne serait pas le cas on
devrait donc retrouver sept ans coche en
hausse de 28,6 cette année à partir du
mois de juin
néanmoins on devrait avoir un écran 19
ne viennent toujours plus grand toujours
plus d'immersion un écran lcd avec une
résolution qui devrait être plutôt pas
mal côté définition devrait avoir du fhd
plus de 1160 par 1080 pixels un grand
écran qui occupera quasiment toute la
face avant de l'appareil
on veut retrouver un dos en verre
légèrement incurvé sur les bords
l'appareil photo se déplacer du côté
pour se retrouver au centre
en dessous le flash suivi du capteur
d'empreinte digitale est suivi en
dessous du logo one plus inquiétant des
empreintes digitales qui d'ailleurs
devrait être un petit peu plus réduit
est plutôt bien positionné au centre de
l'appareil
alors on peut se poser la question d'une
eau en verre pourquoi un dos en verre
c'est vrai qu'à première vue on va se
dire un doux envers pour pouvoir avoir
de la recherche son fils de la recharge
par induction
j'y crois assez peu il se peut
effectivement qu'il recharge par
induction mais globalement je rasais
surpris pour deux raisons principales la
première toute première c'est que si
vous mettez une recharge par induction
vous allez faire grimper le prix de
l'appareil et c'est pas dans la
stratégie de one plus de faire monter
les prix parce qu'ils vont se retrouver
rapidement en concurrence avec les
grandes marques avec les modèles haut de
gamme et là c'est pas forcément leur
positionnement s'il vous rajoute de la
recharge par induction ils ne vont pas
forcément mettre à l'intérieur le
chargeur par induction et du couffo des
vous achetiez par vous même un chargeur
à induction ce qui fait que ça ferait
augmenter la note et on perd forcément
le sens stratégique d'un point de vue
tarif de
plus d'autant plus que one piece à son
système de recharge rapide dash charges
qui vous permet de recharger votre
smartphone très rapidement donc pourquoi
aller s'embêter avec une recharge par
induction à mon avis il vous m un doux
envers tout simplement pour rendre à
côté un peu plus sexy un peu jolie quand
même par retrouver sur les produits de
au nord donc là on voit très bien
qu'avec la petite encoche en haut on
marche un peu sur les plates bandes
d'apple iphone 10 le dos en verre on
sera proche du galaxy s 9 on s'approche
de l'iphone dit on se rapproche surtout
de leur concurrent principal au nord qui
fait des très très bon produit dans la
même gamme de prix
côté performances le guen +6 va vraiment
s'affirmer avec un qualcomm snapdragon
845 de la puissance à l'état pur une
machine qui va vraiment bien calculer
fastier du multi applications que vous
ayez des jeux gourmands ils devraient
vraiment super bien répondre et voudriez
sentir absolument aucune latence le tout
couplé probablement à 8 gigas de ram
côté stockage 64 giga de stockage 128
giga de stockage que vous pourriez
augmenté à l'aide d'une carte micro sd
la batterie aussi devraient très très
bien faire les affaires 3300 millions
père heures probablement peut-être trois
mille cinq cents millions période on
imagine que les performances sont
complètement optimisé pour avoir une
expérience utilisateur nous permettra
d'avoir une autonomie la plus longue
possible mais c'est vrai que de voir
augmenter un petit peu la capacité et
les performances de la batterie ça
pourrait être plutôt pas mal
il nous a tout sous android 8.1 oreo
avec une surcouche oxygène os il devrait
avoir un bluetooth 5.0 de l'usb type c
est toujours le port jack
côté photo voudriez avoir un double
capteur à l'arrière 16 mégapixels
probablement 20 méga pixels avec une
ouverture de f
1.7 dont quelque chose d'assez lumineux
pour faire belles photos quand la
lumière n'est pas forcément au rendez
vous vous pourriez film et jusqu'en cap
qu'à écouter cette fille vous aurez une
caméra de 16 mégapixels
c'est un appareil qui devrait être
dévoilée est commercialisé à partir du
mois de juin 2018 un tarif avoisinant
les 500 euros 515 520 25 30 35 on sait
pas de toute façon les prix ont toujours
tendance plus a augmenté kbc avec une
fiche technique toujours plus sexy de
nouvelles innovations on imagine que
forcément ou être plus augmenter
légèrement son prix qu'est ce qu'on voit
toutes ces rumeurs autour d'une bonne +6
on voit très bien que one plus de
continuer à positionner ses produits
milieu de gamme mais vous
on se rapprochant et en flirtant avec le
haut de gamme snapdragon 845 8 gigas de
ram même si jamais c'était que lucie
jega drame ça marche très très très bien
côté caméra côté photo côté vidéo ça
fonctionne super bien on a vraiment
quelque chose d'hyper sexy alors
effectivement on n'a pas des moggi animé
comme eux pour trouver chez apple ou
chez samsung on va pas avoir un appareil
photo réinventer comme chez samsung
ou alors comme si huawei clip et 20 et
le pev un pro mais on voit très bien
qu'on a une fiche technique qui est
hyper cohérente profitant des meilleures
technologies du moment même s'ils ont
effectivement qu'on se positionne pas
sur les produits très haut de gamme avec
des caméras trou d'eps avec des
objectifs à ouverture variable tous des
choses comme ça qui effectivement font
la différence entre aujourd'hui un
appareil milieu de gamme et un appareil
haut de gamme néanmoins on va être plus
continue toujours regarder ce
positionnement très haut de gamme avec
quelque chose d'hyper sexy un produit
qui est très beau et qui pourra vraiment
comblé énormément de personnes autre
point hyper intéressant c'est
l'interaction va très bien que one +
interagit avec ses utilisateurs avec ses
clients ses consommateurs pour exemple
le tweet de carl paye un des co
fondateur de one + qui a demandé la vie
tout simplement à sa communauté sur
twitter
est ce que vous aimez le port jack
window on va très clairement que ça
permet d'influer pour voir s'ils doivent
conserver le port jack sur leur one + 6
oui ou non pour les amoureux du port
jack rassurez-vous le oui l'emporté haut
la main ce qui est super intéressant là
dedans si vous voulez c'est qu'on se
rend compte que one + qui était déjà une
marque très sérieuse mais bros pas hyper
sexy est devenu hyper sexy en 2010 est
hyper sexy y perdant keable et qu'à mon
avis il serait conservé leur position en
2018 en attendant ils ont pas intérêt à
se louper parce qu'ils sont vraiment
attendu au tournant
on imagine très bien que les
constructeurs sont lents produit milieu
de gamme que ce sommet de samsung que ce
soit a peur que ce soit au nord ouest
nord ont tout intérêt à ce que wall plus
se plante et tous les constructeurs
chinois qui poussent derrière et qui
veulent arriver sur le terrain on
vraiment espérer qu'ils se plantent sauf
qu'à mon avis one + a vraiment trouvé
son créneau va y rester avec des
produits super intéressant super sexy et
franchement plutôt bien fichu au niveau
de la fiche technique d'ailleurs dites
nous ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous pensez que one plus est
vraiment dans le game a vraiment des
super produit et est ce que ce one + 6
tels que je vous l'écris pourrait vous
intéresser
je vous invite à vous abonner pour
rester connecté parce que j'aurais plus
d'infos sur le wan +6 bien
damman on va en parler donc rester
connecté je vous invite comme d'hab
données cd jolie pouces a marqué tous
vos commentaires suggestions question
tout ce que vous voulez directement en
dessous là juste en bas vous pouvez y
aller merci beaucoup d'être toujours
plus nombreux sur la chaîne a regardé
les vidéos à les partager à me laisser
les commentaires à venir me parler sur
twitter c'est super intéressant
je suis très contente pour passer ces
petits moments et les partager avec vous
bon on en reparle très bientôt
restez connectés par ce que vous allez
voir il ya toujours plus d'actu sur les
smartphones les produits connectés il
attaque en règle générale je continue
d'aller me balader vous allez voir il ya
plein de choses qui vont arriver d'ici
là je vous souhaite de vous porter au
mieux d'être très sage ou fait des gros
bisous et que surtout à très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]